or are you always good because I
everything it seems like you always
everything you do you always have a lot
of lines you always are you know boom
boom boom boom do you have this thing
called a photographic memory can you can
you learn things really fast no but how
do you play a guy like data a character
like data well back in those days uh
when I was doing it you know every day
uh it is a muscle and uh you know you
get better and better and better at it I
used to have a deal with myself I would
go home
after 16 hours or whatever uh because we
were doing also 26 episodes a year back
then and um I'd come home and I'd say
okay let me open up a script and my
stomach would turn over you know I think
I could learn this for tomorrow for
tomorrow yeah and uh uh but I had to
deal with myself that if I if if I
couldn't I couldn't go to sleep until I
could say it out loud one time perfectly
so I knew I could do it the next day did
you ever have those nights where you
didn't well you know and the next day
you struggled there were a lot of times
I didn't sleep let me say that because I
had that deal with myself that
unfortunate deal but uh did you ever did
you ever tell the producers like hey can
you back off a little can you give me a
little time to learn this stuff I did
have a I had there was the first season
or two on the show uh we were all
working all the time and then finally
the producer sort of figured out hey you
know each one of these guys could kind
of carry a show and we'll do data
episodes we'll do Picard episodes we'll
do Riker you know everybody had their
shows and uh we would you know there
would always be scenes on the bridge
where you know we would all be there and
sometimes two sometimes three you know
it was always fun to see who you're
going to work with that day but right
um but one or the other of us would
carry the show and uh I was doing a show
I I don't remember what the name of it
was but um
it was my show and so I was working all
day every day and everyone else had done
the first day and they were off the rest
of the time
and the day before we were starting a
new show and I was saying oh thank God
this is going to be over soon and
somebody else's show I get this script
and they're like five characters I'm
playing five characters and it's again a
data show and uh oh sorry I'm getting
anxiety really so like I I've flown the
producer or one of the producers who was
still there and I said I can't do this I
mean this is how am I going to do this
I'm still working on this show and
tomorrow uh at some point in time we're
going to finish this and an hour later
start the next show and uh I've got five
characters I can't even read it much
less figure out what I'm gonna do with
them and her response her name was Jerry
Taylor a wonderful woman wonderful
producer and she said to me we have
faith in you
that was it I said oh okay see and I
wouldn't have hung up I would have said
[__] off yeah well I know I can't I
cannot learn this I well you know you
did it though I I managed to do it I
mean I gave you know I did the episode
that we did where I played the five
characters is an episode called masks
and uh I only remember that because I
get a lot of feedback on it but I do
some of the most Preposterous acting
you've ever seen in your life in it I
mean the other actors were laughing in
my face at some of the characters I was
doing really literally you didn't care
no I mean there was a there was a point
the last when we finally got to the end
of it uh
Patrick and I were in masks and facing
one another at two o'clock on Saturday
morning and uh he was playing the god of
the sun and I was the goddess of the
moon and we couldn't get through the
scene we were laughing at each other so
much that the crew hated us oh yeah
yeah and you know but we couldn't stop
laughing no they see that much fun to
work with Patrick he can be he can be
really fun I think also should be
intense well yeah dramatic I'm sure you
could all be intense well uh you know to
devering degrees Yeah